okay that's share this link BRB sharing
the link now waiting see the chat there
oh no wait
don't had you play the game yet wait can
I go back to like oh can hear old souls
I am messing this up options huh exit to
main menu Jesus Christ
why were you already playing okay I
already made a choice balls oh my god
heart attack okay where's where's the
link
show me the leg
[Music]
do
[Music]
laughs to me man like this van Leeuw
[Music]
duh
okay now where's the chat you guys
probably just laughing at me
oh no you might not see what just
happened oh dear okay chat is up hey
guys okay so I think I first I pressed
play like before I press share and then
the game was already playing and I made
a decision before I even watched it so
we'll see what just happened but hi how
are you guys I'm like naked like three
weeks back at home has tired me out so
much I'm so happy to be back flat like
yes no people I love being alone so nice
but is we're talking to you how because
I've just literally not spoken to anyone
for so long hello Dan hello animatronic
gamer hello catching moments hello Kevin
hello mood Factory hello Ryan Kelly fee
Hey
yeah and then apparently animatronic
gamers I'm sorry I never get to keep up
with these streams
I always upload them there's a thingy
called live streams and cut my hair is
super fluffy today like I can never
bothered to do anything with anything
more and it just goes like this like I
don't know how it just defies gravity
and then I try and just put the big bits
up cuz it's
just like an actual me I don't know how
I can get that fluffy just try and get
out of my face a little bit but yeah
I've been excited to play this and then
I'm so annoyed because I remember I went
home for Christmas and then I realized
that the third episode was coming out
and I was like no cuz I don't have a
games console or anything back then I
was like I can't play until I get home
so no good I hope you guys had a great
Christmas though a great New Year's as
well mm-hmm let's just do this also let
me know if I'm talking to my talking is
too loud or if the game is too loud vice
versa okay I'm gonna carry on but like I
said the game had already started so I
missed a little bit so what that means
you probably missed a little bit so I
apologize
sorry to every stop restart restart
yeah okay well that makes sense yeah
that's true from the beginning ah thank
you but therefore you're like even
though you've seen this episode I I'm
pretty sure most of you guys probably
know what happens in this episode so no
spoilers please reavie ously on life is
strange before the storm
I felt like my dad's been lying about
something for a while I just didn't know
what it was there is plenty of blame to
go around
what does that mean you forced my hand
this is a consequence of your actions
Chloe we both agree that the best thing
for everyone at this stage is for me to
move in this game better not make me cry
nice I never thought you choose David
Moore any feeling emotion with me I
can't go home right this junkie
gerunds oxy for Damon go to Jerusalem
find the money and I'll meet you to pick
it up whatever you do don't open the
door I opened it though Juliette is
Wailing that bernal Inferno is the
culprit closing down the roads and
robbing us of our Ariel no [ __ ]
chance I swear to thee we shall fly
beyond this Isle the corners of the
world are near promo what says them to
my most hopeful wish yes
let's leave
for real if you don't mean this it's
it's just making me feel like [ __ ] that
this life you're describing isn't going
to happen
what would it take to convince you
Rachel that woman you saw your mom that
wasn't my mistress that was your mother
still makes no sense though
I want to tell you all of it but are you
sure that Chloe should be here for Chloe
stays of course in every way that
matters roses my wife and your mother
but the woman you saw at the Overlook
her name is Sarah so why are you still
kissing her birthmother
I'm gonna tell you everything Rachel
everything I was shielded you from for
so long but the truth can be hard to
look at
is this really something you're ready
for
Chloe I'm here I'm right here
good I need you
[Music]
thanks Kevin for letting me know that
audio is fine
I was in high school there was one
person everyone adored her teachers her
friends Sarah was everyone's favorite
every boy wanted to date her I could
barely believe it and she picked me
sometimes I think that's what kept me
blind for so long
she was so alive so passionate about
everything early on though I realized I
wasn't enough for her
while the rest of us were pursuing
college careers families
Sara wasn't looking for any of that she
was looking for escape
and Sarah became pregnant I thought it
would solve everything and it did for a
little while becoming your father it's
the greatest moment of my life so much
love but I was still blind
however much she loved you then
for Sara the need to escape was always
there
she didn't her out
for over a year
I'm trying to help
I made myself believe that she was still
a good person
no matter what happened
she would never do anything to hurt you
I was wrong
eventually I saw her or who she really
was
a destructive person someone who could
never be satisfied
of her I was desperate so I made a
choice I was never going to let her harm
you again
wait
it's the first time they met back up
again what you saw at the Overlook Jill
it was true we kissed
kiss of my life
it wasn't kiss goodbye I told her and I
was happy for her
then she felt like she'd gotten her life
together finally but she didn't get just
decide one day to be a mother not after
what she'd done but after all the people
she hurt all the lives she destroyed I
told she'd been given rate as a gift in
the world the chance to be your mother
and she squandered it it pained me to
hurt her like that
but I'd do it again and again and again
to keep you safe
so did he like not seen her since the
drugs so that was the first time you've
seen her or he's pokin with her in 15
years no I sent her money she send you
money you're looking after the kids our
arrangement but now she wants to see me
yes but Rachel
it cannot be it's not really his
decision hmm why not I feel bad saying
that drug addiction is a disease it
afflicts everyone not just the addict I
will not allow you to be victimized by
her disease again even if that's true
Rachel could still meet her and maybe
the the fact that she wants to see me
you mean she's gotten better maybe so
but consider that for 15 years she's
preferred to that money to you Rachel I
think I need to lie down
oh don't do drugs seriously
these games hit on such tough topics
I can't leave Rachel to deal with this
alone you guys saying hey Bukka could do
it
hey Jonathan hey Michael hey hey huh hey
hey Jonathan
and mr. t Lake done I hope you're all
good hmm yeah this is a really artistic
game so where with the kiss though I I
kind of get the kiss I mean it is weird
and I guess it still we just seen is
like keep doing whatever but when you
get older I don't know I guess people
getting like they understand you know
you have passed things and emotions
didn't just go completely Rachel only
knew half the truth when she set that
fire what if she'd known everything hmm
The Tempest show feels so far away this
is so painful and look at okay
I had a text at night what's my thing
yeah greep SMS bring Rachel a little
seriously come is it like a posse
yeah The Tempest cast party yeah I don't
think they're gonna be given to a party
right now nip nip nip nip should I try
and talk to the dad this must be hard
for you to master amber oh thank you so
much Michael it could be four hours I
appreciate that
my biggest fear had it dance I feel I
dreaded it so that's why you never told
her you have no idea what pain
Sarah's caused her addiction has led her
to do terrible things it's such I don't
any of that it's quite obvious we should
write he'll be up to Rachel to decide
Rachel is curious and determined she's
always going to want to know more I can
believe that she won't be concerned
about her own safety
she never has been you you think sarah
is involved with any of the drug dealers
around here it wouldn't surprise me if
she were maybe Chloe knows him that's
who she is Chloe I believe Rachel trusts
you more than anyone else right now
is this where you asked me to manipulate
Rachel into doing what you want this is
where I asked you to do as your
conscience dictates but please put my
daughter's safety first
I'll tell drew try the truth for a
change what do you mean well you did lie
to your daughter for 15 years this is
true and that's why I need your help
I only care about Rachel Chloe I'll do
what I can
I care about her too you know I know
thank you I want to see how his wife
feels about all this
hey mrs. amber I think it's rose at this
point considering everything okay oh so
good do you need any help with anything
that's very kind of you could you get
out the broom for me it's in the
breezeway door to the left of the fridge
ah they're such nice friends helping her
stepmom
mr. Shetty cool graphic don't steal the
shirts Chloe be getting rid of this
don't take the shirt take the blue why
would you take her shirt and this after
everything has happened yeah yeah I've
got the boom here you go what you want
me to do thank you I'm really quite glad
that you're here
Thanks but why while Rachel's dealing
with all of this it's a relief to know
she can talk to you how are you doing
Chloe how am i doing your generation
loves to talk about how awkward
different things are - it must be pretty
awkward I'd imagine it's fine Rachel's
the one who's really upset she has every
reason to be there are many painful
things about Rachel's past including my
own role in hiding the truth
Sarris shouldn't have taken money over
seeing her daughter you know I am so
thankful to her that she did it gave me
the opportunity to be Rachel's mother I
never knew how much I could love someone
until I had Rachel but hearing the truth
after all these years hurt Rachel more
than anything I'm not happy with James
for the whole way this came out you're
not happy with James what about what he
did at the Overlook it might be hard for
you to understand but after 13 years of
marriage I'm not threatened by what
happened hey guys no I don't understand
art is a bit different than my don't
worry about me no thought I would know
James Rachel's the one who needs you
right now
do you think sarah is dangerous I've
never met her so I don't know but I'm
inclined to trust my husband his entire
life is about keeping people safe
Rachel's extremely fortunate to have him
as her father Thanks Thank You Chloe
she's so sweet and understanding like oh
she's too nice hey I am often
everything's really emotional here so it
can't be like yay I'm actually feeling
really sad about this Oh drugs don't get
into hard drugs kids please please don't
it's waste of money and time in
everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
irony
[Music]
Rachel
I need some way to show Rachel that I'm
here for her
be there for a Rachel hey got it
[Music]
the young and had a seeing of Rachel
amber rachel has so many inspirations
she can barely keep them all contained
know how that feels
Rachel even knows how to make a dinky
lamp look cool
Rachel surrounded by so much love yet
she seems so alone makes sense that
Rachel needs two signs to contain her
awesome cat Sonia
oh I shall call her a lion crab come on
it was two pretty good especially
emerged that - pretty good signs to have
because Leo's are like really confident
and outgoing but they can be a bit like
boys just an arrogant because of it but
cancer alike the most emotional sign so
and the most empathetic so that would be
like a perfect combination no wonder
she's such a perfect person
go home this alight needs more light
I'd love to have like a big one of those
in my room wonder what I could find
around town and brighten up that
nightlight mmm they're so close to
making her break glass oh yeah now is
there a section on how to walk fours
through batshit crazy family drama No
[Music]
okay this could do something
wait she's not fine I know something
miss Arcadia doesn't weird didn't set
the fire the GFI was that there's a
dragon with matches a lot press clubs
like 50% serious presence of shady they
think that fresco started the fire and
my Rachel could use another subject
throw which one
ah and not at me
that's the one Oh see the flowers
at least she'll have something from
tonight mama so cute mm-hmm
hearin you Willie
couldn't come up with the tragedy
Rachel's going through Rachel's really
into stars I wonder if it's her way of
feeling connected
I love seeing people's bedrooms easy
nice and much about money I can make the
world a less scary place the name
Rachel's on stage I think Rachel said
don't I stop so anything's either you
just like drool over my purses but you
know like maybe on post-it note I guess
it a little bit rude but whatever I've
done now I've heard that Rachel and
Nathan hang out sometimes but it still
seems hard to believe
I'm not gonna bother speaking because I
know she doesn't want to speak so I'm
just gonna put this thing in thingy
huh have a fit who would I guess already
for Rachel's light show better
hey check it out
such a good friend it's beautiful I
thought you might like it I've always
loved stars why you remind us there's so
much beauty out there which we almost
never see sometimes we see it
but then I learned the truth the stars
were seeing
I've already been dead for millions of
years
well that's they're all lies they're not
lies but that doesn't make them any less
beautiful right I don't know if they're
not even real and what's the point they
wear once it's all lies everything my
entire life my dad my mom if I can even
call her that isn't more and that other
woman my real mom she's the biggest I of
all I can't trust any of them
I think you're the only one in the world
I can trust I'll take it even if it's
only by process of elimination
I wore this bracelet my entire life I
never even asked why never even thought
about it somehow I think I always knew
even when I didn't know that my real
mother was gone
no sad feel really emotional tonight
this is not begin to play
the fact that she's here right now that
she came here for me I think I need to
see her so wrong what would you guys do
it's a really difficult even not in that
situation about I think I would just I
would have to see yeah just oh if it
just sucked not to no no of course it
might be tough to track her down
yeah that's true
luckily I've got my secret weapon
but what if we can't find her still like
I can ask my dad I would if I was had no
idea where to start
I've been like I just believe this is my
life it's my mom make you're being a
douche got this really mysterious like
she's so cute when she's not it of
course even if we know where she is we
need a way to get her I can't just ask
my parents for a ride
I think I might be able to fix up that
truck in the junkyard
really I'll give it my best I know you
will but even if we find her how will I
talk to her what do we say no Josh
wasn't named after my dad died I was
worried I wouldn't know how to talk to
him anymore
but somehow when we speak I always know
what to say when he's his beak yeah but
your dreams ah he's there and it's so
real
it's almost like it's another part of my
life it used to be the only part that
mattered
I've never told anyone about that weird
huh Rachel I was just thinking maybe I
was wrong before
who cares if the stars are dead as long
as we can still see them that means
they're real to us right right this is
so cute
oh this one starts off emotional like
usually a buildup of I guess the ended
on a cliffhanger so oh is she dreaming
now
she's talking how awesome outfit he's
pretending to drive this time
it's weird dad I think we're stuck
hey maybe you should let me drive you
always do it wrong that was one time
when are you going to let it go
remember when we used to work on cars
together those are some of my favorite
memories
my memory doesn't mean my memories I
don't think you remember after here
Touche alright you why don't you go take
a look yeah sure
what's wrong
don't you see anything so I can either
play along or say this with you there
I'll play along fine it's it's a spark
plug
no that's not it I just had that
replaced
oh thank you Geoffrey's supposed to be
all about yes and I think this game so
far I'm trying well cry I'm gonna cry
dad stop
none of this is real
you're not real Rachel's family is it
real this whole thing it's
it's all just theater well you know what
William Shakespeare said oh my God thank
you so much Nathan Valentine Jesus happy
new year
I feel like I've been very boring
tonight but I'm honest you just tried
not to cry and feel really emotional
this kind of is touching home a little
bit for me that's all I'm gonna say
but it's it's done baguette welds stage
sound and fury well the stage about the
whole world being a stage so might as
well act the [ __ ] out of it nailed it
I don't want to be an actor I just want
to be myself
miscegenation you hit the phone button
did you like time someone out by
accident maybe there's a reason we
pretend maybe the lies we tell each
other are less horrible than the truth
we keep hidden that's pretty dark dad
where do you think you get it from
there's my cue
relax sweetie
it's all pretend right
right yeah just a bit of stage magic
floodlights sound effects
Chloe
look at me he's gonna get it's gonna I
sweetheart
it's going to be okay
you [ __ ] oh this is so sad oh my god I
feel like such a crybaby
it's so sad oh that's all I can say I'm
sorry I'm not being a very good
conversationalist
hopefully I like calm down in a bit just
like keeps on building up stupid sad
episode
stop this why did you sneak it oh yeah
of course
has someone been going through my room
unless your boobs yeah she wouldn't
leave a mess like this don't think I
stepped out what he meant
dr8 would he [ __ ]
whatever I don't have time for this [ __ ]
I've gotta help Rachel okay I saw Sarah
leaving Frank's RV you might know how to
find her hello everyone he likes me and
he owes me one from yesterday I can do
this he's done my weight David is the
set done so yeah dude pick up Frank I
was actually gonna cash in for a favor
instead what do you say
I need to find that woman from yesterday
Sara oh yeah she knows the drug dealers
Frank something important can you help
that yes I did get pop from Frankie the
first episode to breeze I'm having a
friend and trying to help he knows how
as well so why don't you just say who is
um he might do a whole lot to her yeah I
have more than one friend sweet thanks
man
you're a real beep well I guess
what am I getting myself into
oh this games so beautiful I didn't just
spend a few days on unity just learning
how to make make it look good
thank you for being there for me
yesterday or last night I'm feeling a
lot better now guess what mmm you
already miss me well of course but also
by meeting Frank at the junkyard in two
hours I think he can get in touch with
Sarah holy [ __ ] yep I'm stood up my
house just showering and grabbing tools
of the truck so Mia the junkyard I'll be
there you're amazing quite a price I
know okay I've got two hours to kill a
shower would be [ __ ] amazing as a
shower okay
wait I had to text my mom oh she's
annoyed
peace of mind doesn't matter it's kind
of cute that she's still like worrying I
want to just tell my mom
surely she could understand right what
Victoria commented on a photo let's dive
didn't I want to see the 5 cents to see
my work is appreciated
Oh huh
Matt respect no one asked you Trevor
Rachel really is good at everything she
does how hard an idiot Nuka my Chloe
price whoa skips in a band well so much
has changed I wonder if you'd even
recognize me now
California huh would be cool to see
where Rachel grew up yeah
like guys I'm about to rack up a lot
more absences class right a man don't
care oh yeah switch on the radio right
[Music]
what are the plan this is gonna be one
of those tiny tiny extra things to know
all the sugar jozek plants need sugar
but okay last year up to Christmas I did
my own live streams of this episode
three times three times we're doing like
all the different all the different ways
now that's commitment
Rachel and I we're still leaving today
there's really nothing in there that's
worth taking
okay let's go oh my dad's jacket
it's favorite jacket definitely taking
Madoff Rachel
music reach 1 Bray is a [ __ ] evil
[ __ ] oh yeah she totally is yes do you
think you're her little sidekick now yep
you got every line of that play perfect
how could that be
well over whoa you're going too fast
with me you've been planning this oh my
god stop stop stop stop stop stop I
can't read I've had it with this school
nobody gave a [ __ ] by me last night it
was all wait to watch a mature man when
you try to drug someone when if I do in
the ass that's just the worst it's true
how could she think like a Barbie like a
choice in music David's tell where the
hell is mine are they like gonna be down
for you down my towel is probably in
here somewhere
lots of love yeah he just moved in so
they are probably just getting all like
romantic none that way maybe in that way
maybe they think the Chloe's out
actually oh dear we might have something
very uneasy a minute I truly hate seeing
so much of David [ __ ] around here no
awesome pirate towel
of course of course her towel is the
pirate out what's in here
[Music]
nowadays but the whole or rather was
some pirate stuff Max and I were so into
this [ __ ] kids wait a minute
captain Bluebeard's here to die max was
going to make me a pirate this is how
she gets a blue hat you gonna use it
[Music]
ready for the best shower of my life hot
water don't let me down
Jimmy close the door whatever
apparently not hmm gosh awesome don't
say that what I say bye montage thanks
for dropping in
[Music]
she's doing it surely that's not
permanent though they got when they were
kids
yeah no yeah I guess that's why she got
the idea from she was so cool
said every girl ever
hmm what do we wear guys I have some
bonus outfits I have some bonus outfits
okay so we got bad scowl osin
well I'm gonna wear my bonus maybe but
that's the one I was wearing before so I
need to change well excited then thanks
Nick max Kaiba Hey like how you're like
Kaiba here at the end
awkward okay bye
tree where the Arcadia Bay one yeah yeah
yeah no no yeah come on sis let's dragon
yeah good muffin gets dragon Amy brought
me this actually she didn't like this is
what me and ami do all the time we just
like get you to those things randomly
she bought two instead of one bag
something she bought it for herself so
I've got only top now she's like it's
pink it's not it's perfect but I wear
black all the time I was like yeah give
me something with color instead of black
but cuz it's all I wear does black and
white and some oranges and breads to be
fair
okay all right I did change again damn
it no I wouldn't I won't just be done
with this yeah keep that you look badass
what what's the button to say yes other
night one last thing I need to get dad's
tools so I can fix that truck
that's toolbox should be in the garage
downstairs okay let's go downstairs and
figure out what is happening with this
music and they still listening to it
yeah
whoo are you guys ready they don't think
she's in the house that's why they don't
think she's a parent having some
romantic time what are the chances I can
avoid mom David apparently I was
supposed to have a little Newman arty
t-shirt I think I think it has she tried
to download another or install look
another add-on for more t-shirts but
it's failed for some reason because I've
got to see to the past
yeah I'm flipping the malls least we
wasn't having too much for my time three
minutes each side they're gonna burn oh
you're the expert now I'm telling you
it'll make a mess you know you don't
have to make
you cook all the time I want you to have
a break at home you are one class act
David Madsen huh
mom actually looks pretty happy right
now
new this is the hard thing for anyone
with parents splitting a new step father
mother it's the hardest thing to realize
it's like you might not like them but
they make your parents happy and that's
actually all that matters
what'd she do she was like hey who's
there
hey Chloe your hair weekend was this for
the play
I heard you performed last night nope I
mean I did but this is it's something
different
none of that matters now
oh I am so glad to see you
good to see you Chloe coming home was a
smart decision I'm not staying long just
picking up some stuff
oh they should be my mom I don't know I
wish you would tell me what you're up to
yeah no tell oh just no need to lie out
with Rachel oh how is Rachel I was
telling David about the play and you
being in it I really gotta go
listen wait before you go David has
something to say to you well it won't
take but a minute
she's being really nice mom
I don't think this is the yeah you
already promised I'm gonna try Chloe
I've made an agreement with your mother
to trust you from now on I can totally
relate to all of this what does that
mean it means that from today forward
I'm going to take you at your word so if
you say you haven't been smoking or
drinking then I'll just leave you be
but you need to be honest - Chloe even
though it'll be like an annoying good
parent now pod yesterday David say while
looking through our idea is you should
feel comfortable here Chloe David's not
going to question you and neither am I
he did such a very bright maybe didn't
can I just ask him if he's touched my
room instead of accusing [ __ ] it
it's said this sounds like it's doomed
to fail but hey kudos for trying if he
Sanchez again then I'll call another one
I really meant it good job can we be
done now wait one second
don't go Chloe I've been meaning to show
you something maybe maybe now is a good
time this is my friend Phil Becker he
served in the same unit two tours
bedecker was killed near the end of our
deployment roadside IEDs to joke about
all the trouble we were gonna get into
once we got back home but he died he
died and I didn't and I think about that
fact every damn day the point is I've
had my share of grief I know what you're
going through
so I guess what I'm saying is I'm here
to do what whatever I can to help you
get over the loss of your dad just
doesn't sound that genuine but like it's
nice please
he just got a show with that I Marvin
actions over words touch Garrett's mom
too
I'll give him a chance but it's an
actually here
why don't you keep this photo for a
little while
I don't think you think about what I've
said
if you're looking I'm Chloe I don't need
the photo ah but I won't do any with
dick it's all take it but I don't need
it I just want you to act like you
understand young and this fell guy they
look close
so empathy admin hey I think you'll find
I have plenty of that maybe too much
thank you David
Oh mom I'm just so proud of you Karen
and my match they got blue things in
there hey you need to go be careful
Hey look at I love you sweetheart
all right all right what the hell
my knees move to end so just gotta grab
dad's toolbox and then get out of here
quick oh crap
this might actually be helpful for
fixing up the truck say thank you David
but it's padlocked soul
oh sorry Lucas it was very last-minute I
just tweeted out cuz I wasn't supposed
to be home today wasn't really supposed
to be home till like this weekend but I
just had enough of like my hometown was
like anything so I left and I was like
yeah I'm back with my PlayStation so I
just figured I'd do a lot you
oh yeah Twitter's the best place to keep
up with
back in the junkyard
no home Rachel didn't go Rachel found
out that her mom is that she a drug
addict
come on and that woman wasn't actually
her mom
[Music]
but now we're trying to get the work
with Rosa fix to fix to get fixed
how was my Christmas it was good it's
just just I just wanted it I don't
already have a bedroom I hurt so I'm
like oh yeah it's nice to have my own
space but it was nice my family and my
grandmom yeah it's good
better I hope you guys is good but still
needs a bit more
thanks for the promo I can salvage this
beast I just need to find the right tool
for each problem ok let's turn the radio
listen to some music music makes and
everything but it looks like someone
sometimes before I was born I think that
ancient duct tape is better than
anything I really glad expiry you do
need it what's wrong with it
it's fine I won't fit sit on the
distributor cap excess gross playa maybe
no I'm gonna help
what's wrong with this this connection
is pretty sugary I could fix this
battery post if I could get a good
enough grip on it lyov now you go there
fits like up deadly electric glove
nothing you say Chloe I think I should
move on to something else
it's pretty loose how can I tighten it
could you use your pliers designers not
helpful no nothing
what are we else ah we have a wrench in
a screwdriver
so wrench yeah
[Music]
she's so fat a Scully she's so cool much
better
sweet last uni today if only because of
this easy to maintain your face I agree
I like this type of music sure don't I
think it sounds pretty cool
um skip this few drivers guessing and
didn't even listen to us yourself I'm
guessing these and listener
oh wait watch to go off hello
Yeah right
[Music]
that could have gone in your mouth crazy
[Music]
whose Evan
that should help keep [ __ ] distributed
Oh
well sis air quality health advisory
mark to heavy smoke expected okay
Oh David messaged me he's missing last
night
no this morning oh sorry this is David
did my event you should it you did it
[ __ ] your father still works are you
working I thought it sort of what kind
of projects oh I'm real busy I'm glad to
see you taking an interest in something
keep it up no become sending just dad
came by Tabriz thanks for coming
[Music]
sparkplugs question
carbon deposits
please I need you
sweet we have a working car think yeah
be careful with it don't break it
[Music]
Freddie
freeze up crash
[Music]
she is such a badass she is such a
badass so he is a badass
then she wash our hands I think why is
it she admiring her blue streak junkyard
Queen where are you at I'm in my
penthouse Hey
holy [ __ ] your hair it's so blue badass
I was gonna say hot but yeah badass too
that shirt looks awesome too I might add
you like anything that starts fire hmm
I'm not sure if you saw but someone
moved your truck no way should we check
it out
hey price nice wheels Thanks picked it
up myself you're early
Frank what's the occasion
obviously huh did he do you for [ __ ]
Bar Mitzvah Frank here's big guy
what's he doing here hey I thought we
were cool after that drew North thing
don't you want to be cool don't who's
gotta say I really dig the hole tough
girl thing Frank was right about touch
her how'd you like to work full-time for
us what being a drug dealer no I'd
rather not
don't [ __ ] touch her yes yo Rachel
why is it that chicks think it's okay to
hit me but if I lay a single finger on
them you would already grabbed her it's
a whole other thing
Frank says you're asking about a client
is that true yeah no it's true I don't
see why you should give a [ __ ] you don't
maybe I'll show you I am I'm so truthful
to Nancy no I decided it would be a good
idea to call your drug dealer and ask
about his business I didn't go to a
fancy academy but that doesn't strike me
as smart maybe it was this man's sunny
disposition that confused you but he's
got a whole other side to him but I
don't think Frank's a little puppy let
them see if we're just talking here
okay then let's talk I want to know
right now why you give a [ __ ] about this
one
Rachel why do you sum up why do you care
so much because [ __ ] you I'm asking a
question here look none of this matters
all we care about is that you stop
asking questions
fine we'll find out some other way leave
us alone No tell me where she is now
Rachel wait a minute have they talked it
I think they know no way what the [ __ ]
is your racial as in Rachel amber
huh that makes so much sense
this is James Amber's [ __ ] kid
Damon your dad's a real piece of [ __ ]
you know no my dad's we don't have
anything to do with him right here's
what happens next
come on man they're just kids why
they're not this one is the [ __ ] DA's
daughter and right now she's going to
fill me in on what her daddy is up to
and how he's connected to that [ __ ]
everyone's asking about Damon
everyone down who else it's after Devon
everything's still cool need to get
crazy [ __ ] I like Rachel she's gone
she's gone
okay too bad what the [ __ ] no obviously
it
[Music]
[Music]
uh-uh I used to get something about your
back so you're AB up your frickin jumper
around quick and then go
Wow that did not that is not in well I
don't know it was another way for that
to end though and then I was like oh my
god he stopped I was like oh wait no she
got died because we know how she dies
but yeah that was pretty crazy mmm
Wesker says if you get stabbed in the
upper arm you get bleeding very fast you
hit an artery
that's fingers crossed she doesn't I
mean we know how she died so she's not
gonna die but yeah I know this this does
not bode well yes Nathan this is very
intense right
[Music]
[Music]
present dr. Rachel is going to be
alright
the knife damaged her brachial artery
but didn't cut it
she's out of surgery and now she's
resting
Chloe what happened it's my fault I
should have listened to you she did tell
him that you were gonna tell him how
with this psycho
do you mean numeric I know exactly who
Damon Marik is yeah he knows who you are
he's not very happy and tell me
everything
did you and Rachel try to contact Sarah
I'm not going to chastise or she's in
the hospital
oh I wish I could just wait until she's
so welcome I got my dealer Tim he does
I got my dealer Frank yeah that's right
but Damon showed up with him
what did Marik want he was scaring us
away I think you wanted to scare us so
he'd stop asking questions about his
business cuz he said that everyone was
asking about Sarah how it became well it
seems to know much about Heather
if I'm right yeah I did when he found
out Rachel was the DA's daughter he
wanted information about you and how did
he know that I'm her father
I don't know you actually
I don't know maybe he's seen her before
oh wait did I just lie it happened next
I just have a chill like Rachel could be
anyone I felt we all could see it but
then he said something and she just
grabbed a piece of wood and him and then
he stabbed her I keep thinking that
maybe I could have done something but
when he attacked her I just froze it's
not it was alright fast Frank held him
off so we could get to the truck I heard
a scream but I don't know what happened
then we were here you guys saying that
Barney Chloe thinks it's Harry she
shouted racial well I think that's
ridiculous like Rachel pull some strings
with Ray
maybe get you back into blackwell
what about Sarah what if Rachel still
wants to meet Sarah after all this I'm
hoping she'll finally see reason
oh you would see the extended she would
come to you don't Lea a few minutes
later she might not have fun Thank You
Chloe
ah you saved this wasn't necessarily
Sarah I know obviously it's some time
before Rachel she is hanging out but he
didn't seem to know all that much about
us
I'll let you know what she does okay
thanks
hey Steph how's Mikey pretty good miss
amber just told me Rachel's going to be
okay I'm really glad yeah well our rooms
just down the hall you should come by
okay sure
definitely let's play more D&D at the
hospital no II don't think they I don't
think so those days have gone mm-hmm
I don't think I can sit still any longer
no saint
well stretch my legs while they wait for
a Rachel okay okay but first I need to
go to the toilet BRB
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
I always do it just to see if I'll freak
anyone out because you don't know that
I'm coming and my mic Kiko I meet so I'm
just like hahaha
um anyway just carry this on what ya
grumpy with beer that's amazing what are
you on about Lucas ah
Joel mrs. max I don't actually nothing
like she wasn't a good character she was
but just so much going on I just easy
for yet but max to be honest mm-hmm
Nathan those networks screwing up
I screamed P beer did I scream P beer oh
I screamed BRB be right back
ponies son like PB r PB yeah that's so
weird
okay carry on
my vision no just see who gets it okay
let's assume let's have a look around
so please shares anything to graffiti I
can sit on the little pirate ship she
always wanted to be a pirate being in a
hospital this long sucks
I just want Rachel to wake up and then
I'll feel better I owe Frank big time
can't believe he did that for us yeah
but he's so in the first life a strange
game though lie anything about it in one
way are these Frank and Rachel I'm gonna
Pat had a thing going on by it
is he gonna come after us I actually
feel better knowing that James amber is
nice case oh that's weird
yeah cuz it seemed like Franken Rachel
amber were like together but the more I
play this the my think like thinking was
definitely together like these two Chloe
and Rachel I know they could be like a
very close friendship I have my
suspicions but I need to stay busy shush
I'm doing stop do more around here we're
doing stuff that border kick it come on
not that I have any coins anyway man
jackpot we have a broken vending machine
in uni and it's great cuz basic you
kitten you play tip you pick one then
you keep your like spam the okay button
and it just gives you as many as you
want
it's great you gotta be really careful
doo-doo-doo-doo did it little bit there
just want my chocolate bar please yes
yes
she deserves that she's been waiting
there for a long time I want like 20
more of those hey ed man 25 homeless
woman wait what where what what what you
see I'm wearing room 75 yeah I know
god you're so pushy
right let's go I saw you go into that
room anyway 7775 this is the one hey
Anthony he's on the phone right thank
you
hi mr. North that's me and you are I'm
Chloe
here to see Mikey yeah
Oh how are things going oh you know how
it is
ups and downs my keys hurt of course but
the doctors are saying it should heal up
relatively quick Andrew hey maybe heard
he's all set to go to Oregon State full
ride for four years that's that's
awesome oh no you said you were Chloe my
keys mentioned to you a few times now Oh
Oh question maybe you can answer sure
both of those boys have been acting a
little well guilty oh why do I have to
be the voice of reason noise a train for
work I'm worried I missed something
important do you know if anything's
going on with then you should probably
ask drew yeah I don't really know any
details I do know that whatever it is
they did it because they wanted to help
you Thanks clothes nice I know they've
been trying to help me out
money-wise we're a family you know we
deal with things together excuse me
sweet okay do I have to sign that is the
sign as I do I have to sign my name
before I enter can't cold
I love Teddy's so if you guys notice
they usually have one still need to wash
my other one cuz my friend was sick on
me but I have Pikachu here today so
Chloe hey you made it
Oh Chloe
Hey how's the arm Mikey
I wish it was the other one so I could
draw and stuff but other than that it's
just broken sweet hair by the way you
could pull off Sailor Mercury oh thanks
any news about Rachel her mom seemed
hopeful how she could hurt you'll think
I'm joking when I tell you but I'm not
why what happened Rachel was stabbed in
the arm like demon king Marik yeah
that's you serious
[ __ ] that guy it wasn't because of me
was it
don't mind oh no we got our own set of
problems with him that's crazy
the whole thing makes me want to just
don't smart at pizza I ever meet that
[ __ ] I'm gonna what what are you
gonna do when you need Damon there
something terrible I am like karaoke
challenge him do a karaoke battle yeah
that's how we settle things on the
street huh okay throw dice at him
criticizes taste in film okay tell him
about a band he's probably never heard
of but should have anyway we're glad
Rachel's okay oh you should hang out
here till she wakes up
Rachel's gonna be up soon she probably
head over when I'm ready yeah I will
let's just look at these flowers friends
those must be from Steph's parents
that's so cute oh I love friends and the
circle so cute let me sign your cat hey
can I sign your cast yeah definitely hmm
something nerdy but not too nerdy
I'm it obviously
there you go she did like the whole
freakin she did do that the whole
frickin cast 40 happier than she's got
to come the board game night soon yeah
say hi to Rachel for us routine can I
have that he's so cute I guess
he's kind of mustache it's adorable what
do you mean can I speak to this dude hmm
I was kind of nice that I Stefan drew
aren't leaving Mikey side it's cute he's
lucky to have them yes sweet look at
that walls being nice for a change
okay that's nice I let you feel my
listen turn into a cartoon contest I
hope you wins ah for its superhero
design that's so cute
love it aspirations good ones I approve
Mia did I miss the real part visit okay
let's get out hey wait up a sec sorry I
got angry at you yesterday about the
money you were just trying to help
that's all right don't worry about it
well they check out myself I don't think
say I'm really tough joshan dissolution
beat out so I created when you said that
Damon's dad Rachel I kept thinking I'm
supposed to look out for Mikey not bring
this [ __ ] into his life I think you
saved us from something so much worse
thank you yeah sure
anytime thanks for stopping by
bye Chloe
well was i cold that the D&D game was it
barb no I can't remember
this is mr. amber Rachel is just waking
up now I'm sure she'd love to see thanks
I will go to see her I'm glad he's not
hungry ass these firefighters have been
looking at us just heard the fire wynant
those guys look exhausted minutes
controlled no it's completely out it
extinguished itself how could that be
fine that's so weird
wonderful it does have something to do
with Rachel um because I knew that's all
people were speculating I literally
don't know anything about this episode
by the way I've kept away from it okay
Annette's PTAs Hey
Chloe I can't even express thank you so
much I'm sorry a wreck I stepped out to
get some air
Rachel doesn't mean any crying in front
of her your hair I almost didn't notice
it
oh yeah it's it's not a big deal like
that rachel loves it i thinks it's hot
imagine what I would do if we lost her
me me too Wow you've grown so close
haven't you yeah it's weird to think we
just I did those ago by Kitab thanks for
coming who changes everything
you just know Wow
hang in there mrs. amber I will I love
her she's such a lovely mom person
you guys are so cute in the chat you're
like thinking everyone likes you English
is good it's 92 Rachel the pain will
pass
Chloe's here you want me to stay no
I'll be ok thanks dad I'll come back in
a little while
my guardian angel says hey I'm gonna ask
how she is best not great better with
you here Rachel I'm sorry what what for
you're here because of me because I
choked back there in the junkyard what
shut up
you were so fierce and I just froze
[ __ ] it up I'm so sorry and you saved
my life you saved my life just don't do
that again play the damsel in distress
you got it no attack a psycho with a 2x4
that was crazy
newsflash Chloe I'm a little crazy
the best people are crazy heart
happy that your dad's here I mean I'm
still mad at him for everything he's
done but it felt so good to lean on him
he's my dad you know I felt completely
safe like Mount Hood
would you do something for me anything
Sarah mom
so weird to say I'm not even sure what
she is honestly but I think I still want
to meet her slowly you do what it's not
like she did that I don't even know if
she's still an artic Katie obey but if
she is will you find her please you
really want this don't you I do Chloe
I really do
then of course whatever it was she could
just talk to my dad remember maybe in
his office and just be like look I did
all this just runs and find my mom
please just let me see the code is zero
seven two two two your dad's office zero
seven two two yeah my birthday
I'll find her Rachel
and then I'll zero seven two two two two
zero seven two two zero seven two two
Thank You Chloe
for everything
I didn't tell us it's always said hi
bringing wait your hair it's different
that little Hotel given all the games I
love it yeah yeah I like it it's it's
nice I like your shirt too
I didn't know you were into Dragons who
the [ __ ] is intended Ragan's true nice
balloon nice balloon thank yes yeah it's
from Mikey oh [ __ ] I should have
apologized I'm actually here for Rachel
what Rachel's here what happened
uh if she keeping in private because
those guys name I don't ask you if I
think she's keeping that private for now
she's okay though huh that's good
I guess I'll stop by after I see Mikey
she probably wants privacy oh right of
course ari are you doing some kind of
trouble you can tell me if you are you
know I won't judge what I don't even
know what you mean it's kind of weird
that Rachel's being so private isn't it
you know it's really not Chloe
I'm seriously worried about you well
don't be a very good reason will become
clear hmm I mean you're hanging out with
Rachel amber a lot lately
right so what
so obviously obviously you're jealous
sorry it's really okay swear I'm fine
we're fine leave is mine okay okay
he's pretty annoying breathing a lot
just remember I'm here okay sorry I'm
just like it's in my ears I need
something okay thanks bye anyway see you
I mean he's nice
see you around Chloe
look I wish you could just tell us like
I like you do you like me or are you
with with Rachel or am i overthinking
like just have that conversation if
that's the conversation that you're
trying to have people were never that
upfront it's never that easy is it
I'm glad her a big agrees of me on the
briefing and apparently you guys seem to
think that he's like his motives aren't
sincere hmm we'll find out I guess we'll
find out
hello
Oh Bulls what was it
0-7 2207 - - I think oh it's okay she
knew that I'd it right power myself
okay here we go
gotta be sneak sneak sneak in I need to
search this office for any communication
with Sarah as it can help me find her
yeah and I'm not gonna be able to smash
my way through this one hopefully
there's a key around somewhere
James sure keeps lots of files on people
to be nanhee jailed Scott is that even
if James is trying to protect Rachel
from her mother this seems like a pretty
terrible way to act
he sent someone to talk sense into Sarah
okay graffiti yeah why not he's gonna
know she's been in there someone's been
in there but whatever Chloe doesn't care
she's badass oh my gosh he's definitely
gonna know oh dear dear dear
more sherry okay um Sheldon why do I
feel like I've heard that name before
have we heard that name before guys oh
you don't know I don't think so dad ago
best dad heard stuff is all politics
anyway
hey was like the key well that was
convenient so I decided to look at that
trophy huh found you
nice okay hey for I am visiting of
course good luck with whatever you're
dealing with be safe that's some all of
us oh that's a nice mic sister Chloe she
can handle anything
Jose that's cute
they're also such good friends okay
let's open this man
how many that name was commentary
episode number yeah you might want to
open it instead of like a ban what's
that a tape recorder it's a famous purse
so she was trying to stay in touch with
them to Rachel she's when I stopped
missing you but now I'm in a place where
I know I can be a part of your life it's
much more it's more than I was there by
name she's waiting straight to Rachel as
well how long ago was this it's arrived
me write to you again haven't heard from
you the clink lovely knows I'm so afraid
afraid that I'd be a terrible mother to
see that screw you up and you know my
fear is born for West Oh
why is this making me sad it's just like
sad to know that it's like she's been
trying to get in touch with her and
that's so sweet
I read somewhere maybe a fortune cookie
never stuff it in the seat never step in
the same room twice because after me
it's just not really the same ever
anymore
saying ever that's a sweet little saying
I like that I try to put you put you
reading these letters I wonder what your
reactions are I imagine it out is to
worry of this that's okay James protect
over you and she's been so nice about
her dad as well oh this is so sad I
can't run the way this letter doesn't
seem anything at all like the person
James told us about last night I have
gone through rehab I'm in recovery I'm
no longer in need of money I'm coming to
like I know I can reverse it I'm going
to Acadia Bay if you have any feelings
left for me at all you'll give me a fair
chance to prove myself to you and
hopefully to Rachel - you were the love
of my life once please believe me
I mean it's so hard because of course
she was she was a drug addict so it
totally makes sense but she's trying too
hard and she's going through rehab and
she's like shown that she's better now
dear mister amber I represent Sarah
she's even gone through freakin lawyers
Oh so this looks like Sarah stopped
cashing the checks Jane Center she's not
even being nice he cashed to mention
that during his story last night oh my
god
I have to know who James is talking to
on the secret phone of his it's got the
pieces about Sara
maybe it's the present that he sent to
to scare Sara my first it's really itchy
but I hate things touching my feet so I
can never it's my feet which is really
annoying anyway yep
how do I give up how's your daughter
don't weigh no freaking way I just read
you know she texts me fret attacked me
first bite
yo she tell me first wait you really
should teach her to behave he's for
messaging him he's a messaging you in
the drug dealer sure he can because I
talked to your girl and she has a big
mouth Korean 15 whoa
so is he trying to I'm told you can
happen my problem I'll quit tonight I
found who you're looking for coming 15
Wow
I'm gonna need you to each I can't sure
he can I gotta talk to ya she has big
mouth turns out she's not so easy with
getting my hands on Jesus so he sent him
to care about Sara I freaking knew it
because what are you talking about he
was like everyone's asking about this
girl and it didn't sound like he knew
her or not girl you know it doesn't
sound like you news working with Damon
Merrick this is insane what were they
talking about is the girl Damon's
talking about Sara of course whatever is
going on I need to see if Damon knows
where sara is but how do I get him to
tell me
you'll pay I mean here's the DA did you
take care of the evidence played what
what am i saying why did I say that huh
[ __ ] what do I say you first I don't
know what you're talking about
I knew you're new at this so I'll keep
your past don't [ __ ] with me that see
proof of the evidence what evidence I'm
so confused
oh dear hope James actually has this
evidence don't think Damon will tell me
where sara is unless I send him a
picture
dude what evidence I'm very confused now
sherry you want to see this sherry I'm
saying abuse getting your ass kissed
comes with a DA territory it's not even
nice lots of files on people anyone know
what this evidence is I'm very confused
about what this evidence is Sheldon why
do I feel like I've heard that name
before files don't be sleepy oh wait
isn't in the fire James has a file on
Frank I'd love to read this but I've got
to frost this bow as mom okay what about
the the snuggler
yes waste time it's the big one
mine's Mia the last last episode of life
strange not the last one like the last
one press one oh maybe this may be the
crime arcadia base at least wanted
what's this Marik finder sapphire Booker
hasting the victim no no my cold is this
the evidence what's in the box
this must be what Damon was talking
about what it says evidence on its oh
[ __ ]
which of these is Damon talking about oh
god just take a wild guess
Oh God says well maybe there's some info
on the case hanging around the office
[Music]
and through on the case hanging on
oh yeah no I know I know I know I know
okay exit I just glanced at it but I
think it's this thing here right so
after a verbal altercation with the
victim Merritt brandished a fire poker
hitting the victim for fantasy mercs
gloves gloves ah la lalala lalala lalala
la loves its gloves okay he's being was
the words uh not framed like you know
he's blue like not doing his job because
you're whatever our town I can't do
words ballistic gloves
I'm waiting yeah 90 [ __ ] destroyit
why so part of this oh okay maybe he had
a plan or something but it looks like
I'm gonna have to destroy the gloves can
I just get some good gloves how do I
destroy a glove I can burn it somehow
burn baby burn disco inferno
I could put some sherry on it just think
anything in here there's no lighter in
hand we go to the kitchen Oh
maybe not but that would be that would
be the easiest way or just burn it in
the waste basket huh
Oh
obviously it's Chloe price she's got a
lighter on her die
okay take a picture quick quick quick
take a picture
dick is the Big Shot better not touch
that again
hey Joker yaga yaga yaga III I says
you're destroying evidence might as well
tell me which of my guys was a snitch oh
don't make me do more things just tell
me for Oh
no more Tim I hope James has something
here to tell me who demons informant is
so I need to find which of Damon's guys
has been snitching I should search her
on the office to see if there's
certainly a victim I buy so everyone
else is anonymous okay if I'm going to
accuse one of these guys I'd better be
sure I'm right Oh No
I don't know I'd even know him most of
those are it's just such that there they
wanted to remain anonymous
[Music]
can I read these files okay this is that
freak from the mill I wonder what Damon
would think of his very cooperative
comment no miss chickens okay I got
agreed to aid the courts on future cases
that could be seen as a little snitchy
mm-hmm maybe it was this guy Joe with
Scots
what about Frank
thank you Dan okay there's no way that
Frank is snitching on Damon and I loved
learning about his badass loitering
charge
hmm no I wouldn't do it to Frank this is
gonna be that guy right so Sione yeah
it's gonna be this guy I hope so too
ade the courts on future cases that
could be seen as a little snitchy gerald
Scott's
yeah you guys are saying that you did
innocent ones okay so I'm guessing his
jailed Scott his jealous got there oh my
god
what where's Gerald Scott I totally knew
this guy was a criminal when I stole
from him he's that one who this gotta be
gerald
Gerald might know this who's Sheldon
confuse what I'm confused as Gerry from
the mill I wonder what Damon would think
of his very cooperative comment
I agree to aid the courts on future
cases that could be seen as a little
snitchy
just frame the biggest joke but yes
there was of our answer I want to do the
right one I'm just funny confused
so it's Gerald Scott by how do I know
like which one he is and what he looks
like gel it's got and now it's
definitely not Frank don't know who that
is
Sheldon Thunder who the hell is Thunder
this guy let me into the mill cool dude
oh my god thank you so much oka I gotta
go I love this challenge community ah
thank you
you'd best can't have a happy new yes
user did you say that no you didn't put
Happy New Year anyways I don't want to
do this guy because he looks nice
so who's this could this douchebag be
the snitch demons talking about Sheldon
Pike
that was the other guy wasn't it I don't
want him to be that one then but he's a
totally new this guy was a criminal when
I stole from him the Sheldon Pike was
the other like folder by Sheldon Pike
you guys think if he didn't but it was
just an email to what's-her-face oh he's
the snitch but you so much
wonder if there's someone else I could
pin it on instead
ya know how long I'm gonna be doing this
what's this why is there little speech
bubble now looks like a recent email
from Rachel's mother to James
even if James is trying to bribe man
this guy's this yeah he was so cool to
me at the mill I wanted a I wonder if
there's someone else I could pin it on
instead
boop-boo-boo-boop I don't really know
that guy but I know this guy mesh bag me
the snitch demons talking about cuz he
was the one that punched us as well
right am i right pin it on pike he was a
douche yep okay doing it doing it [ __ ]
really I barely know that guy
oh no causing some trouble where that
took me so long video I was like I want
to make the right decision yes all that
leads pay up show me you have my payment
what
how much mmm you Pig stole for me still
does not house hoping James already has
demons money but where would it be
nothing with the evidence I mean I would
have said in that locked all but
obviously it's not bad I mean I wonder
if this has anything to do with demons
stash
he's shady man all this good dad stuff
holy [ __ ]
alright taking the picture
[ __ ] that's Sara and she set the mill
why is you tied up what is he doing to
her
oh my god oh my god
once let it go you really are new of
this how about I leave her body on your
doorstep room in the cash then we can do
all this [ __ ] just James even know what
he's doing
Oh Lou I still have time he let him go
on a case money break I'm paid him he
wouldn't do anything sit her kill this
woman yeah that was the love of his life
I need to get there fast
Elliot oh my god hey Elliot what are you
doing here stop [ __ ] me you doing
here
this is Frankie's house right guess
she's my friend you really just follow
me here
did you did you follow me from the
hospital I did there's the reason I'm
fine you're the one acting crazy you
shouldn't be here Chloe
what is oh say out my stuff put that
down
you have no idea what you're dealing
with and you do Chloe what have you
gotten yourself into you you wouldn't
understand
give me a chance
what the hell are you doing serious i I
I can't tell you but obviously this is
pretty serious [ __ ] that's why I need to
leave right now
you mean serious for racing everyone's
like this but but you're the one putting
yourself in danger again I'm so sick of
you not I wanted to really let me choose
my own decisions of my own life it's
what she's doing to you Elliot just take
a step back no you need to listen to me
what has your relationship with her
gotten you you you don't know what
you're talking about first night you
hang out what happens you end up in a
fight
ah I can see why you'd think that but it
wasn't her fault it's never her fault
that's the point stop stop suggesting
that she's somehow bad fourth day she
convinces you to skip school magically
she barely gets in trouble and you get
expelled
that was me as well she did defend me
Rachel was there for me she did
everything she could to protect me I
guess it wasn't enough huh you don't
understand
you weren't there was she protecting you
when she made you take part in a play
you didn't want to be in God look I'm
sorry I ditched you for the play but
this isn't about even a bad thing that's
cool seriously man you need to shut the
[ __ ] up before getting quiet long enough
look and I don't mean onstage she's fake
Wow he's your real and I hate to see her
manipulate you like this Elliot I
promise no one is manipulating me No
just look where you are now a high
school dropout hanging out with
criminals and breaking into houses it's
crazy it just as easily could have been
you in that hospital today if that ever
happened
ah so I do appreciate the concern like
I've seen it I mean and like if it's a
mere issue
speak to her dad I'm the one who cares
about you Chloe me not Rachel it's time
you saw the truth but he's doing it in a
very Oh
competition away like it means you're
going to stop thinking about Rachel and
pay attention to me now oh my god he's
got like the stance of an angry ape I
dive time for this [ __ ] look I'm sorry
dance out of this I really need to go
he's gonna hit me why did you make me do
that oh my gosh this is pretty tense
if I call for help people gonna know
what I've done but I don't think I can
calm him down what do you guys think I
didn't know should I trying to arm him I
don't know
I'm actually waiting for you guys I'm so
confused kick him in the balls don't you
touch her
apparently you can okay I'll try and
come hell yeah please I know you're
upset okay trying to help you now let's
go for help
last vertical I need to get the police
to come without tipping him off who was
there for you when max left when your
dad died he's like no one else gave a
[ __ ] about you except for me you have a
lot to talk about and I don't care how
long it takes we're not leaving until
you see that I'm right I hate these
people who are like I've done everything
for you therefore you owe me everything
it's like no doesn't [ __ ] work like
that sorry
all right I like it you want to talk so
bad let's talk okay let's do this what's
really going on here
you can tell me
okay right now we are here at twenty
four twenty lakhs rires Road is that
what you mean sure they can trace the
call anyway right
you're acting strange what's going on
what nothing I
what are you know bulls you [ __ ] Oh
can't you see I just want to help you
you're going to assault me now that's
how far you'll go to protect Rachel this
is what I'm talking about
no what you idiot what the [ __ ] better
run dick bag cops will be here any
minute
go Chloe go go go take that money and go
go go Darley go get Sarah oh my gosh
that was intense
that was intense that was tense that was
tense oh but it still works
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well this is why you should always drive
safe guys so much destruction all
because Rachel got angry at her you
think that was that see Rachel was that
actually made to her oh hey
being a dad's tough oh hi doesn't just
have dad what he's done I'm just saying
I'd probably do anything to keep you
safe
hey Dad yeah
did you ever lie to me cause everyone
lies telling me that ashtray I mean her
mom wasn't a piece of crap I mean like
really lied about
something that might hurt me to know
what do you think
sinning everyone lies about big things I
mean stuff mom doesn't know about me so
you probably like yeah I guess when I am
a superior I mean we are willing like
alive really almost mess
I guess it depends on what it was that's
the trouble
sweetheart the truths risky and the idea
of you loving me even a little less I
don't think I'd ever want to risk that
are you really ready to hear the answer
to your question
whether he lied to her
No
yeah ready as I'll ever be problem is
I'm dead
exactly so how am I supposed to tell you
anything
I guess it's better this way not knowing
then I'll always be the perfect dad
gasps so many people get to say that
don't worry my ride my toes
[Applause]
am I seriously going in to face a
monomeric for Rachel I crazy crazy you
don't want me to go no I like the
company Saints
we don't wanna miss this things are
about to get real
[Music]
oh wow doesn't do a dad bits get me I
always get emotional um dad had dead
head oh [ __ ]
hello
oh god yeah [ __ ]
is that blood this Frank soybean maybe
he beat Frank up pretty bad after we
left oh well maybe this happened here
but when she goes in there and they see
it's not James are only gonna freak
[ __ ] this is bad I'll get you help Frank
thanks for the promo made the tea Laden
which was mom okay she's going in I'm
not sure where but I think she has the
money on her
Jacek so cool
where the hell is Sarah
[Music]
[Music]
don't mess
don't tell me what to do
[Music]
glad to see the barmaid
you might need that later just in case
little precaution okay so that's his/her
needs been using to text to know if it's
the one he takes us with but the other
dude
Frank's couch is toast it's a different
it's Frank's counts just because he was
sound at one time but okay we'll go with
that um well they're going no more beer
one more time I've got to keep moving
everything's going to be just fine just
a little longer and all your troubles I
just want to meet my daughter can't you
understand why this daughter Jesus he
did he was no that's what he's worried
about can't let the public the mother of
his daughter some junk I just want to
see her you don't have to shut up James
amber wants you out of the picture so
that's what's going to happen
this is so messed up
after all no one believes it junkie no
he said you've been sober a year respect
it's hard to kick this [ __ ]
you can do this stamen what the hell are
you doing here I don't want to use the
knife sir oh I got you honey I've got
your money right here the money James
owes you how the [ __ ] do you write no
one has to know just just let her go and
I won't say I'm so noisy sure use a
freaking knife you boosted the da's [ __ ]
got my money burn the evidence I'm just
trying to help
let this be a lesson kid make good life
will end up like her now what do I do
gaming what did you do
[Music]
I [ __ ] you up good didn't I guess you
really don't know when to quit
we're glad to see you back on your feet
Chloe
freak you don't really want to do this
again do you okay then I don't want to
do this again
come on oh [ __ ] you it was a good wine
timer which I was freaking max why now
oh I feel stressed out
[Music]
Sara Chloe price you know who I am I saw
you in the play you were funny Thanks
she knows Sal Sara are you okay
we need to talk about what happened I am
so so sorry for Rachel can never know I
think you need help
let me let me call someone or something
I need you to listen what James did
hiring that thug shooting me up with
he's a piece of [ __ ] and I promised that
Rachel can never know tell me why
doesn't she deserve to know what her
father did no Rachel deserves a loving
father the father who cares for her
James is a large Ames
is a desperate man who loves his
daughter and she loves him tell her what
happened here and she'll take that away
from her dad forever
yeah she is the don't you think the
truth matters more the truth what's so
great about the truth Chloe why are you
saying all this because James is right
he's taking something from me that I
might not ever get back but he's right
I'm broken everybody's broken Sarah Oh
does everybody abandon their own child
for 15 years you tried you send this
letter everybody take money to stay you
stop taking the money you're here now
that's what matters and what do you know
I know Rachel needs you I know robots
I lost my father two years ago how car
accident he was he was picking up my
mother from the grocery store and a
truck ran a red light and that was it
I'm sorry
you don't know what this is to me every
pain every fear gone no more sadness no
more grief why would anyone not want to
feel that way ever
I I don't know anything about addiction
but I know what it's like to be needed
by someone it gives you strength you
never knew you had Rachel needs you
Rachel needs her family I recognize I
might not know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about here but I just I wish you could
know how amazing rachel is I know she's
fearless she's brilliant and talented
and she feels so much she's so strong
she's had a good life raised in a loving
home given opportunities I could never
give at least talk to her she's felt
like something's been missing her whole
life she told me so that something was
you she didn't miss anything
she has a perfect family but it's not
real even without all the [ __ ] the
Amber's are far from perfect James is in
the latest [ __ ] and Andros lets him
walk all over her maybe
what Rachel needs though is not to have
her father taken away from her he
doesn't deserve what about James it's
not about me and it's not about you it's
about Rachel make sense for what Jesus
did and you'll be killing him for her
you understand don't you
you lost your father do you really want
to put Rachel through that
the letters the worst mistake you ever
made was giving Rachel up that's what
you said in your letter to her by the
way she didn't read any of them that you
don't have to make the same mistake
twice
nothing can change the mistakes I made
hmm I'll never get to be Rachel's mother
not really
but there's one thing I can still do for
her the only thing I can do let me give
her the father she deserves the one who
raised her protected her the one who
loves her more than anything you can do
whatever you want Chloe you have the
power what you have to decide oh no is
whether you're going to protect Rachel
or cause her even more hurt [ __ ] this is
so please tell her I was never here I
don't have what peace she can without me
wait
[Music]
don't leave don't go Aaron I'm done here
goodbye Chloe
I don't want to make this decision this
is a [ __ ] hard decision that's
horrible I don't want to it cuz I always
think you should tell the truth like I
think the truth is better than anything
but then I totally get where she's
coming from cuz if she knows this she's
gonna hate her dad little ever and a mom
like my clothes might not even reach all
these reliable and her mom seems to have
chosen the easy option which is just to
go and go back to the life of being high
I know she'll be thrilled to see him
when she wakes up because she knows that
he's already been able to raise his head
well a little later Hey go back to sleep
kiddo you need your rest can I talk to
Chloe alone for a minute okay sweetie
we'll be right outside
oh oh it's so hard like you guys are
like oh yeah the - what are we getting
I'm getting very emotional tonight this
is so not not the game we should've
played tonight like I guess found that
says it'll be a six-car love skies loot
at is an order to go with the one you
gave me
[ __ ] yeah he never actually escaped
did we we've got time
all the time in the world so how did
everything go
Rachel I've gotta tell you something
[ __ ] a duck
you guys are seeing the truth it's so
hard like in real life if it was like my
best mate or a love interest or
something I would like I think I don't
have to tell them truth because you'll
be seeing them every day knowing that
you lied to them but at the same time
it's just so freaking hard because you
would literally have to tell them truth
and then be like oh but by the way your
mum told me not to tell you because
she's now gone so now both your mom and
dad [ __ ]
there you go but I'm still here like Oh
so freakin difficult
hi today I'm reading your comments now
and it's making me feel like all torn if
some of you guys like the truth is
always better than others of you're like
I knew what happened to her and the
first life is strange so I lied to
protect her so she had a happy life
until she died and so you were like her
mom's druggie [ __ ] okay um
you'll regret it I'll regret what you
didn't tell me which decision I would
regret love is best yeah love is best
but I don't know which one would be more
loved [ __ ] I could let you sit here
forever oh I don't know I don't want to
lie to her I don't want to wreck her
family either wish I could just like
leave talk to her dad tell her dad that
I know everything and then be like you
have to tell her or I'm telling her but
then that still her finding out the
truth isn't it yeah I think I'm very I'm
wavering on the truth I just don't think
I could lie going through all that or I
think the only way I could lie is if I
lied and never saw her again
ah the left down I see lying is hard but
it's best for her right now it's true oh
my god since I like press X that is
coming out Sunday is it is it gonna come
out someday
oh my god is it may if you didn't take
the bracelet off Rachel after - instead
you went for kissing I didn't go for
kissing I know that
okay someone said if you lie I'm gonna f
you so I'm just gonna tell the truth
oh my god I feel so bad but then I feel
so bad if I don't walk it oh I hate this
car
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
you think the choice is hard back the
whole family for the truth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hopefully we at least got that guy in in
jail that maverick I
I gotta get married
at least they're okay
[Music]
[Music]
that's kinda cute
[Music]
see she is happy it's okay
[Music]
we take her up to the spot where our
wait oh did we take max up no no this
was either access place
[Music]
that's cute
[Music]
thank you for the donation Edmund just
trying to hold back the tears
yes it's awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey that is a gift toy - how - Rachel
end up a Frank
I wouldn't know that - oh wait you
didn't cheat on us
No
oh my god I'm so sorry about my emotions
like freaking crazy right now
oh such an emotional thing so cute
though I think we chose way cuz even
though she lost her family which sucked
but import them closer so that was nice
[Music]
okay ghost pay hey she says don't skip
[Music]
I want to talk more about how I feel but
it's like I'm so emotional I can't like
[Music]
I've just come from like my family of a
Christmas a lotta lies happen in
families and it does break people apart
so I think having someone who you know
you can always trust back
you guys stop you're gonna make me cry
you give me all these donations Thank
You Yaga laughing I appreciate that
yeah does she buy my ham maka
need my own comment graffiti everywhere
I did that once I went into the mall in
town when I was younger and I had a
marker pen and I would write like little
like messages that were if it wasn't
Chloe messages it was like I love you
and you look lovely today it was like
little hidden messages so people would
find them there on post-it notes though
because I were actually graffity so yeah
but no that was cute cuz I wrote them
all around I put them right in between
you know we used to go into like music
stores me other posters I put them in
between there and then I went into like
bookstores and I put them in let pages
of books some people would open them to
read them it would be like you look
great or like you're a wonderful person
I'll have a nice day or whatever and
that was cute you cry because you did
from I didn't do wrong I think I was a
lovely ending but yeah yeah cuz I I
think I don't know like I guess life
doesn't really matter when you die this
is king morbid now but I'd like to know
that whatever life like I live or my
friends live there at least are living
in like a true one I think they know
yeah I mean some people would think
differently like ignorance is bliss
right but mm-hmm I I don't think so
and yeah would be painful but like I
said you know their relationship got
strengthened and she knows that if Chloe
could go through all of that and still
remained truthful
like super weak doesn't ever have to
worry about her lying's her ever really
I think that's that's really rare you
know thanks for watching the show James
oh can skip Paris tonight let's go I'll
just carry on talking to you if I may
I'm watching here and this you do even
after two reason hola
we aren't friends sorry got carried huh
what I'm confused
yes you can don't get emotional it's
only a game I know it just touches on
stuff oh oh oh I can press oh okay
settle it's behind my light okay I think
I skipped something oops
whatever you told Rachel the truth Oh
fifty-one percent didn't tell her the
truth that's interesting
64% attacked did I attack - oh yeah
that's in the first one isn't in the
first one yes in the freshman okay
you killed the plant bisoder I killed it
I knew it would die
you accepted Davis photograph 19% people
did that see most people just just
should be polite
we'll take that you didn't have juries
money at the start of the day was I
supposed to have to lose money what was
I supposed to have gotten that oh my
head's in the way I can't ma bird you
revealed to Damon that Oh Sheldon 53% of
people did that one you didn't meet her
mother Rachel didn't meet her mother
what there was a way from Rachel oh yeah
if I use a freaking knife Oh idiot oh
whoa oh here we go
[Music]
[Music]
so Joel power couple
17 missiles
oh that's horrible uh uh yes I want more
life is strange away I can't do that
I'll stop the broadcast ah yes that was
emotional
they all are emotional I can't help it
I'm so emotional but I like that I like
these games because they like really
touch on your moralities obviously it's
still just a game but it really makes
you think about situations and if you
are like a naturally empathetic person
it really gets under your skin because
you're like oh what if you just stop
thinking about everything but yeah like
it's really interesting cuz I mean most
of us probably won't go through things
like that which is a good good thing but
it's quite interesting to see how how
you could possibly act in that way and
the only thing close enough to
understand that about yourself is
through a game and also it's not you
know it's not been too detrimental to
your mental health because it's still
just the game so yeah that's good
this is why I like these types of games
they're really really good Peroni but
Vanessa ships Max and Chloe - nah I
think they were definitely a friendship
especially because they were like a
childhood friendship as well I never I
never ship them I always wanted a max to
get with Lauren go away but um
no definitely Chloe and Rachel are a
good pair they're like fire work you
know passion all of it all that good
stuff anyway
Nathan you missed so much but it's okay
I'll keep this up so you guys can watch
it anyway I'm gonna go now so I go back
tomorrow thank you so much for watching
it's been it's been great just to chill
out with you guys I've been waiting so
long to play this episode so yeah it's
been good to come back
and yeah I will see you I might give
another livestream tomorrow I mean I'm
still gonna play more of the evil within
- I've still got more of that game to
play and then I need to start looking
into other games that I could be playing
for live streams but anyway follow me on
Twitter please
twitch is like where I will keep you
updated daily on pretty much everything
so if you follow me on Twitter YAG my
next and you have my necks and
everything I'll let you know but usually
it's Wednesdays at like half eight nine
ish is when I stream but I was just back
today and I was like I can't wait to
play this game I need to play it now so
that's why I'm live-streaming now but
anyway I hope you enjoyed this thank you
very much for watching I will say
goodbye individually to you guys now so
I'll say goodbye to everyone that I can
see in the chat so if you say goodbye to
me I'll hopefully say goodbye to you
goodbye ghost PhD by Peter Haran goodbye
Vanessa
goodbye Joel goodbye Lucas goodbye
Wesker goodbye mister T Layton goodbye
Thiago goodbye Yaga Mothman skip I did I
say Nathan goodbye Nathan goodbye Peter
goodbye from dough goodbye oh not yet
you are the same person
goodbye Ryan goodbye oh my gosh so many
Jonathan goodbye Dutch Nintendo 94 you
by someone friendly oh that's nice
someone friendly in the chat good bye
Lucas goodbye Jessie goodbye Akash
goodbye Nathan goodbye Ryan
goodbye foul Randy on to bye Chloe price
goodbye Chloe price goodbye pizza I
think that's I think is everyone that I
can see goodbye Silvia and goodbye
everyone lacking in the chat because I
know is probably some of you guys there
because I am very much for those people
when I watch live streams in the check
in the check and the chat
oh and goodbye Michael and no mercy and
man group and I think everyone else
everyone else goodbye goodbye
if I have ooh I love it day or evening
bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye rivers always my
so quit pot goodbye key bugga bugga